seconds
[Music]
[Applause]
seconds
that's what I'll give you to decide your
fate
[Music]
what did you do back home
I'm retired
pain death for you
because of these people I'm beginning to
understand real peace
they see you as one of us now this is
where I'm supposed to be
foreign
[Music]
there's like cancer
[Applause]
no cue
who said you could come here
you should stay out of other people's
business
whatever it is you and your friends do
do it somewhere else you warning me I'm
preparing
this goes to level four you will on
yourself
[Applause]
seem like a man who understands violence
you can't take that from me
that can take anything I want
police found multiple dead bodies on
that farm in Sicily did you kill him
[Music]
nine seconds
do I look like a killer
foreign
[Music]